um there's been a lot to take on board
hasn't there today we've been hearing a
lot about the economy the various
pressures on it at the moment the jobs
market how to get higher wage work back
into the economy as well we also heard
the former bank of england governor's
view of the current state of the economy
and talking about some particular cost
pressures that are particular
to the uk um
importantly as well we got on to the
green agenda and what he's hoping to get
out of cop26 of course time for that
very much
running out to get those pledges through
the door we need to be talking about
that as with our panel as part of our
next big idea um as the world comes out
of the pandemic we need to be thinking
about how businesses
build back green and also how they build
back their balance sheets as well and
the inevitable tensions between those
two
we'll be talking about what the
government can be doing what it is doing
what it should be doing
all of that i'll be discussing all of
that with my panel who kindly assembled
here for us this afternoon but first our
business correspondent helen ann smith
i'd like to welcome her back onto the
stage because she is going to set the
scene ahead of our discussion helena
thank you sam afternoon everyone so it
is now pretty well established and
pretty well agreed upon that cutting
emissions is in theory the right thing
to do what's a lot less clear is not
just how we do it but crucially who
should be doing what and importantly as
well how exactly are we going to pay for
it so first of all let's just take a
look at where we're at post this big
economic recession we've had this huge
shock to the economy has it left us with
emissions that are higher or lower than
what they were before the pandemic well
the answer is um so so as you can see
there the pink line is the uk average so
the average emissions were ever so
slightly below what they were that 100
line uh in 2019 and we've plotted on a
couple of key sectors there and as you
can see the general story is that yes
there were a bit of fluctuations
particularly there in the spring when we
came out of lockdown the economy all
reopening but things were sort of
roughly what they were the key outlier
an exception as you can see in the
orange there aviation emissions in that
sector significantly down but of course
we all know that wasn't necessarily by
design but because of the restrictions
that that sector was laboring under now
a lot of people said that as we were
pumping billions into the economies
different countries doing that to
recover from the pandemic this would
have been a really good excuse a really
good opportunity to invest in more green
and did countries do that did they use
this opportunity to make their recovery
spending green spending so essentially
what we've done along the bottom line
here is the percentage of covered
recovery spending in different countries
that was green spending up on this axis
here essentially at the proportion of a
country's gdp that the spending was and
as you can see there are a couple of
countries belgium canada who really did
prioritize
green spending as part of their
recoveries but the larger economies
particularly those as well who were very
hard hit by the pandemic
not so much and essentially i think what
this is showing us is that when chips
were down when times were hard it is
difficult to prioritize this type of
spending and perhaps that's not hugely
surprising because we know this stuff is
expensive we know it is really really
difficult and i wanted to show you this
just to give a bit of an insight about
just how difficult and just how
expensive it might be this is the uk's
uh sort of domestic carbon emissions
going back to 1990 as you can see
they're going down we know that the
targets are hitting at zero by 2050 but
just look at this when we add in the
emissions that comes just from the
import
of goods so that part of domestic trade
hugely higher probably hugely harder to
bring down and we have to ask ourselves
after a summer of supply chain problems
the importance that we're placing on
global global trade right now are we
going to have the stomach to really
radically overhaul that system and how
we're going to do it it's going to be
very very difficult
indeed so who is doing what well what
this is showing you is the percentage of
companies cities states and regions and
countries who have actually made net
zero promises so far so 61 of countries
have made some sort of net zero promise
but look companies only 21 of the 2000
largest companies in the in the world
have made a net zero pledge at all
however when you look at the quality of
the net zero pledges that have been made
by countries and companies slightly
different story this big chunk in the
yellow here from the countries
essentially shows us that of those net
zero promises that have been made a lot
of them are just at that stage of
proposal or discussion however companies
when they have made a zero promise much
more likely to be in the purple their in
policy document in strategy essentially
a sense that if a net zero promise is
made by a company it's being taken a
little bit more seriously worth just
pointing out that orange bit there
companies have actually achieved more of
their net zero promises as well but
still at pretty low levels so huge
problems huge challenges not just in
terms of what to do but how to
prioritize it and very crucially as i
said as well who's going to pay for it
sam thank you
isn't it
thank you um as i was saying to discuss
what companies and government we can see
what they've pledged and what they're
actually doing can do to promote green
growth i'm now joined by four people
around here with direct experience
of policy and indeed in practice in the
area we have
ash amir amadi the managing director of
allah foods uk welcome to you we have
diane gilpin chief executive and
co-founder of smart green shipping
alliance welcome to you as well we also
have lindy stone from friends of the
earth the sheffield coordination
for friends of the earth there and we
have vicky price an economist and former
joint head of the uk's government
economic service so thank you very much
for giving up your time to join this
discussion here with us all in rotherham
um i want to start by
asking you what your perception of the
uk economy is i mean it feels a bit like
it's at a fulcrum moment as hopefully we
emerge from uh from the pandemic we have
green issues very pressing
um and a number of short-term issues as
well we were hearing about mark carney's
perspective on it all earlier
if i could start with our
business owners um
ash to you
first because some of these short-term
issues i'd imagine are things that are
impinging quite a lot on the way that
you normally do business if you just
give us your broader perspective on the
economy and
the state of your business as you try
and navigate through that
so we're a food business
and of course like other food businesses
have been navigating uh the pandemic
making sure that food flows uh to
consumers
um and uh
there's been a number of disruptions uh
all the way through i guess the
disruptions that we're working with at
the moment is a shortage of labour
particularly driver labour
that's an industry-wide problem
and just simply being able to get the
product from our factories to
supermarkets is a real challenge
what sort of size labour shortage are we
talking with you so we we
um are very mechanized when it comes to
our production of milk and dairy
products in the factories but we need
drivers to to take that to uh to the
shops uh on average we're delivering to
about 2 300 shops a day
and we're regularly not able to deliver
to about 10 of our shops so that gives
you a bit of an idea of the type of
shortage that we're dealing with and
this is a very kind of
you know everyday items so when shops
don't have milk that tends to sort of
cause concern um and
therefore the the type of issues that
we're facing as a business at the moment
tend to be more operational um stability
type issues
and i guess at the same time we're
making sure that we still have that
longer look
on how we develop our business in the uk
so whether that's capital investments to
bring more production handle the
production of our farmers but also make
the necessary investments in becoming
more climate friendly which i'm sure
we'll talk about more as the panel
develops yeah of course
many things to discuss i just want to
come back to you on on one thing in
terms of investing in the various
aspects of your business and do you have
the confidence to be doing that at the
moment because the economy economy it
feels like it could go any which way
doesn't it at the moment
yeah i think it's
it's it's it's coming out of the
pandemic and there's still a lot of
uncertainty as as we go into the future
investment is a
um we're a farmer-owned business so our
farmers actually own us and an
investment is something that we're very
used to doing over a very long period of
time and therefore
we have continued to do that in all of
our operations so
our farmers uh you know
are very keen to stay in farming you
know for generations and therefore the
investments that they make and not just
short-term capital investments but
with the idea that the next generation
will have a farm that's in a better
state than they uh they inherited
themselves and just a final word from
you before i move on to diane about um
how this huge hike in energy prices
might have impacted your business
it's impacted all aspects of our
business um and energy is clearly one of
the key uh cost drivers but labour
it's another one we're a food company so
packaging rises as well so inflation
would be one of the key issues that
we're navigating as a business okay and
uh diane let's bring you in here and
interested very much to know your view
of the economy but also if you could
just give our audience a bit more of an
idea about your business and what you do
yeah so we're a purpose-driven startup
and we focus on the global maritime
industry
and so
in 2018 and 2019 we invented a wing sail
and
went through a feasibility process with
academics
demonstrated that we could save 20 fuel
and emissions from
huge ships by retrofitting this
technology and we're on a roll and it's
going great and everybody's really
enthusiastic about it i feel like
there's a buck coming that's about
coming
comes and so the mum so it really takes
the wind out of our sails you know the
momentum literally the momentum goes um
everybody's focusing now on how do we
deal with this pandemic how do we deal
with this crisis and so having a startup
to come along and knock on your door and
say oh by the way would you like to have
that conversation we were having it no
we don't because we're focusing on very
survival
so
what the impact of that is so so i the
way that i see this
covid crisis is that it's a kind of
there's a word that i've heard
shudderation is that what's what it
feels like the economy has just come to
a kind of shuddering
halt it's still moving forward but is
this an opportunity for us to start to
rethink how we build it for the future
and what do you think what's your
initial thought my thought is we have no
option i mean the climate crisis is so
great that it makes covid seem like you
know something that we we managed quite
well and i think we've got a lot of
lessons to learn from how we manage
covid um and we can we can do the same
with the climate crisis so i think
there's a lot to to learn but it isn't
easy
and it's talking about those lessons is
there anything that you think that was
the key lesson that needs to be carried
over
for the way the economy needs to now
develop yeah so i think what what we've
been seeing is a gap between invention
and innovation so we we're good at
inventing stuff we're good at doing
lab-based uh research and then we're not
great at supporting pilot projects and
and then we
we've then put that technology out into
the world and other countries come and
scale it up for us what we saw in the
pandemic was that all of the r d the
research and development that had been
done in the pharmaceutical industry laid
the groundwork for the vaccines to be
produced in record quick time and that
was because there was a focus this is an
emergency there's a focus let's put the
money behind it and we need that same
gap funding on pilots and demonstrators
in renewable energy and green projects
yeah it's interesting isn't it how
necessity is always the mother of
invention and innovation from what
you're saying there vicky i want to
bring you in here i know economists
never agree on anything you're famous
for it i'm interested to know what your
assessment is of the uk economy
now and how well we are positioned to
embark on a green uh
building that green well for the moment
of course as we know we're in the middle
of a gas crisis we almost had a fuel
crisis there'll be other crisis as well
because inflation is going up all across
the world commodity prices going up
staff shortages you were covering that
earlier of course in the economic
session you had
so all these things are extra precious
for firms now if you are to seriously
move into
greening your manufacturing or your
processes more generally or your
offering then you do need to spend some
money to be able to do that and right
now there is huge pressure on
working capital quite a lot of firms are
seriously indebted um of course they
were helped by the government during the
the coveted crisis
that period is coming to an end and of
course there are still loans outstanding
which are on low interest terms and over
a period of year years that they have to
be repaid but nevertheless they need
more and the new loans that they're
taking are more expensive and require
all sorts of collateral and so on so
smes are suffering the big firms
particularly the energy intensive ones
are suffering too and yet we are relying
on the big firms in particular to do
that investment so what it requires now
is for the focus to switch to
an awful lot of risk sharing from
government so yes we heard from dan
about the issues of innovation and can
you really
upscale whatever it is that you develop
as a pilot
and that requires
quite a lot of risk to be taken by firms
because you don't really know which
technology is going to work in the
future that the government needs to
absolutely step in
to be able because some of those sectors
are not yet profitable are they in solar
and wind are looking good electric
vehicles looking good but there's still
a lot of sectors that perhaps you're
taking more of a risk well some of
course which are becoming very
profitable again
are banks so the financial sector is
doing reasonably well and of course
quite a lot of the firms depend on money
coming to them from the banks but of
course what the banks are also saying is
a number of sectors are not going to be
sustainable in the long term because the
the climate change issues are such that
you know even if you're in the house
building sector are you going to be
building the types of houses which are
indeed going to be
insulated sufficiently they could
survive any climate change changes that
take place uh the heat and so on or
whatever it is that may emerge which is
very different to what we've got now
so they're going to be a lot more
cautious in terms of who they lend to so
again you know you have an issue there
too as to whether a number of the firms
that
make up now the ftse 100 or the wider
list of companies that are in the stock
market whether many of them will be able
to even get the loans that they need in
the future so i think we are at the
point where a decision is to be made as
to what type of economy we're going to
have and what we're going to be
supporting but you can't let quite a lot
of the companies which at present um
hire so many people
and which are quite important in terms
of exporting and in terms of prosperity
in this economy to just go under
as
there was a fear just a few days ago
that would happen because the government
wasn't stepping in to help some sectors
of course you help them to transition
but we now realize that transition is
expensive yeah and i didn't think we put
enough money aside for that i don't know
whether you heard uh some of the numbers
that uh mark carney was coming out with
but he said that relatively short period
the time ago there was about five
trillion that has been put aside from
balance sheets going into meeting net
zero commitments that number is now 90
trillion so there's been a lot of
progress in a short period of time do
you read any optimism into that or do
you just think it's a drop in the ocean
no the good news is that uh because of
covett when nobody was investing the
sectors that did quite well and the
companies at equal well did put some
money aside so there had been a huge
difference between
you know some sectors that really
survived quite well the crisis and
others that needed an awful lot of help
there is a lot of money aside that
hasn't been invested a lot of money held
by hedge funds so even you know one
hedge fund blackrock is is
reported to have assets of about
9 trillion anyway
and that money is not right now being
invested more generally across the world
economy in
projects which can be productive and and
lead to perhaps the types of stuff we
want to see happen in the future in
terms of technology
a lot of it is being used to buy
government bonds or is being used to buy
back shares now dividends are beginning
to be
returned to shareholders again so
that money is there the real question is
is it going to be used the right way
what we're finding though now which is
very useful is that
governments at least are beginning to
move a lot more into raising money
through the issuing of green bonds so
the eu is doing that today it's the
first green bond 12 billion now of
course 12 billion in relation to the
trillions we've just been talking about
is nothing but at least it's a start
isn't it um we have had a question from
the audience which i'm going to pose in
a moment but lindy i want to bring you
in here because i don't want you to be
sitting there twisting in the wind while
we're all talking um vicky was saying
there that we need to decide what kind
of economy we want do you think the
conditions are right now for a green
recovery for a recovery for economic
growth where the environment is at the
heart of it
well i'm sitting here as a an amateur
and i i you know back to the expertise
around the table i'm a local
representative of an international
campaigning organisation which puts me
in a different sort of criteria gives me
a different look in it certainly
amidst all the horrors of the pandemic
last year and difficulties the the
phrase emerged within the campaigning
organizations not not from government
but the phrase emerged to build back
better and this did seem as though it
was an opportunity to do things
differently um in indeed in the way that
diane and vicky have picked up already
and the ash referred to as well in terms
of looking at the business so
i liked that idea of the shuddering and
the shuddering of the economy because it
certainly felt as though something
different could happen and had to happen
last
last year it had to happen as a result
of the pandemic and we certainly feel
that that is a moment that needs to be
grasped it's it's an
a terrible thing to say but it's an
opportunity to do things differently
because
a mindset shifts the mind
and to a certain extent the very
uh the extent and the range of things
that were done to uh counter the
pandemic the uh the innovation through
the vaccination and the you know the
development of medical treatment
actually made you realize how things can
be done if they are taken seriously so
we saw actually taken very quickly
because it had to be dead with the
pandemic people were dying
are you do you have any confidence that
the government has a detailed plan for
its own net zero commitments have they
sort of got that urgency into their
climate thinking
um i have absolutely no confidence in
that and i think that would be shared by
most climate campaigners because
the it is always it's always true isn't
it that the urgent trumps the important
and the immediacy of the crisis that
we're facing on a day-by-day basis um
obviously most um notably but with the
you know the fuel prices the gas prices
that are currently happening distract
from the longer term issues that need to
be addressed
because we have to do stuff about the
problem today
we are each time putting off and putting
off action on the crises which are going
to hit us further down the road and
clearly the climate nature crises for
those of us who are who spend a lot of
time thinking about these issues um
need addressing need addressing urgently
and the longer you leave it the more
devastating the consequences will be
and the more problem there will be in
addressing it i was quite um
i think taken aback when i first was
aware of the yorkshire and heinrich
yorkshire and homicide climate
commission that they are both looking at
mitigation of reducing the carbon impact
of industries and organizations around
in our in our area but also that they're
spending a lot of their energy on on a
adaptation so we know that there's going
to be massive floods we know that hull
is in danger of going underwater in 50
years time or i'm not necessarily
getting those figures completely right
um and that we are going to need to
spend a lot of money
countering the all the effects of
climate change that have already arisen
as well as
uh
preventing them getting worse in the
future so the the important cannot be
allowed to be trumped by the urgent and
we need the government to take more
significant action well it feels like a
good time to bring in a question from
our audience we have a question from zoe
loveday from ssk uk where are you zoe um
talking about the role of government and
i suppose also thinking about how much
of this should be carrot versus stick
yes hello um my question is almost
prefaced by everybody has an
environmental impact or sitting here in
this room today has an environmental
impact and ssk sheffield sustainable
kitchens has had an environmental um
conscience for the past 14 years
um obviously it's become a lot more
trendy nowadays of you know green
washing has become much more widespread
but my question is what would you want
to see
as
the
next sustainable step changes for the
industry from either the government or
all the all the wider markets to be able
to support smes to make more environment
environmentally conscious decisions more
quickly
you know sustainability is expensive we
everybody has a choice to make
sustainable decisions all the time
whether it's personal whether it's
commercial they are not necessarily and
it was touched on before economically
viable at the time and what
what can be done in terms of education
in terms of actions in terms of
accountability to flow further through
industry and down supply chains to
support smes that do want to um proceed
with this in future
diane do you want to pick that up yeah
i'd love to thank you um
so i think
so i think what we need to be focusing
on the ipcc report that came out in
august referred to the urgent need to
drive down emissions in the short term
you know we've got lots of plans about
decarbonizing the economy by 2050 or
2040 or something like that what can we
do tomorrow what can we do and i think
there are countless smes who are
coming up with all sorts of ideas and
solutions and we don't get a seat at the
table very often it's driven by big
business and there's a lot of money in
big business and it's critically
important i mean i think one of the
things i want to say is that we can't go
from you know where we are today to a
totally decarbonized economy overnight
it's not it's a transition we have to do
it in a transformational way but there
are there are
things that we can do now that will
start to drive down short-term emissions
and the thing that i would like to see
um
two things i think i'd like to see
subsidies removed from fossil fuels
because that provides a really
unbalanced
playing field we see the global economy
is driven by
fossil fuels which are subsidised to the
tune i think the international monetary
fund last week said
11 million dollars a minute
and so when you're saying when we're
saying that environmental products are
more expensive we're not competing
directly but if we were to get 11
million dollars a minute to support the
transition to green economy then we
wouldn't be expensive perhaps so i think
that that's a really important thing to
be doing i think the other thing that's
important is that there is hardware
technology in wave wind tidal in our
sector in maritime where there are lots
of smes who are developing solutions
that can drive down emissions in the
short term
in the next two or three years start to
take carbon and emissions out of the
environment now or buy time for those
other
big
energy transitions to alternative fuels
to to kick in and start putting hardware
to test and to pilot um so that we can
get verifiable results because nobody
wants to buy something that hasn't been
trialled so we've got this technology
it's great everybody in the industry
says they love it we'll buy it when
we've seen it work in action we cannot
for love nor money get well love
probably we can't get the funding to
take it to trial and it's a tiny tiny
amount of money particularly in the
context of you know 90 trillion
dollars was it yeah yeah um the constant
thread coming through all of this is the
the tension that exists with you know in
business when you're
trying to pay your staff and all the
rest of it between the bottom line
and your environmental
credentials and ash i'm interested in in
your business i know that you pledged to
cut
carbon emissions by 30 i think by 2030
and you're also very focused on this
even back as early as 2005 when you were
cutting back on single-use plastic
i believe so you'll have a good
long case study as to how
those kind of actions have impacted your
bottom line perhaps you just talk us
through it
yeah no i think um
we've had a long history of of you know
we rely on the land so we we don't exist
unless we we show respect uh for the
land and we take that uh responsibility
seriously so our farmer owners have been
collecting data so doing climate check
data actually they actually started a
complete company-wide program where 9
000 individual farmers you could say
individual smes
of the larger organization they
collected uh 2 000 points of data around
climate exactly what data and it was
everything from the carbon footprint of
the farm the emissions the various
differences
maybe the welfare
what happens to the water usage so a lot
of data and that data is very useful
when you aggregate it because first it
gives you a relative and absolute
position in terms of our footprint but
enables us then to compare data
and drive programs within the business
to improve
our position i think the challenge
when i talk to my farmers
is that they
realize and they have ideas and we do
trials of things that reduce our climate
impact but they typically take
investment
right and and typically the challenge
for a farmer is how do i balance that
decision between investing further in
the farming projects that i know are
ultimately right for the farm as well
over the long period of term
economically but in the short term it
costs versus all the other pressures
that i've got whether it's labor
inflation and so on and i guess what our
farmers are calling out loud and clear
as we go into the sort of period of cop
26
is a clear and an ambiguous kind of
statement from government for its
support for industries like ours or
sectors like ours that are being
proactive
on climate and initiatives and therefore
giving confidence for the investment
we're not actually asking for the money
we we want the confidence that our
investment will pay off yeah we've got a
question from the audience which i'll
come to in in just a moment but i'm
interested as well in the
in the sort of philosophical tussle that
you might have i mean agriculture uh
contributes more than 10
of emissions globally
um
do we need to get to a point where
people need to just stop eating what
you're selling
well well i guess there's a there's a
big debate around uh the food products
that we um so so our perspective on it
is that um we take our responsibility um
and and we think everyone is responsible
uh for the for their role uh in in the
health of the planet and and we think
about it in terms of the planet and in
terms of people
so we see that it's also important to
feed people we've got a growing
population and actually the product that
we're in dairy
is safe affordable and accessible to
many parts of the world as well and
therefore we need to be able to continue
doing that but then also reduce our
impact on the climate so the way that we
look at it philosophically is that if
we're committed proactive and reducing
our impact on the climate then actually
that gives us permission then to do the
safe affordable nutrition for the people
feed the world and save the planet it's
a no pressure no pressure on you let me
um
i'm going to put this question to you
ash but perhaps also maybe vicky you
want to come in on it as well
question from natalie mcguire from
welcome to yorkshire natalie are you out
there
just hold on a moment we'll bring the
microphone round to you
it's about um the way in which
government
should be trying to get involved here
yeah i was listening to a really
interesting debate this morning on the
radio actually driving through around
where the financial incentives should be
used for uh organizations that are
proactively working towards their kind
of green commitments and financial
deterrence for those that aren't working
and the debate was actually around kind
of oil refineries in the production of
methane gas where i appreciate that's
not specific for yorkshire but it does
raise the question as to whether we
should be focusing on incentives or
deterrence or both um in these kind of
circumstances is it time for radical
change what do you think ash
well i i think it's it's something that
we are constantly having to
consider when it comes to our farmers
because they both own the business but
rely on us as management to advise them
on how to run the business
we think it's a combination of both
actually uh incentivizing but also
having sort of policies or regulation uh
in place that drives behavior i think
ultimately what we're interested in is
what drives the behavioral change and
for a sustained period
so so that's how we uh and and
ultimately um what we're interested in
is can we back up the changes that we
want to make with the science
so what so what we're concerned about is
quite often the debate when it comes to
climate change and action is quite
emotive in nature and therefore where we
would like to instead of debate more is
a much more science objective
set of sort of change programs
that would be our take on it vicky
yes
i agree with that but it sort of links
in with the
links to the earlier question that was
asked about you know what do you do with
all these smes and how do you help them
and indeed i think being able to monitor
your carbon footprint is quite important
so you need to have the data to be able
to do it and know therefore you need to
do in terms of improving
uh the situation that
does require some investment and maybe
that investment can come from the big
firms that
use you as as part of the supply chain
for example
um
one of the problems of course is that
right now because companies are trying
to reduce their costs big companies as
well
they're cutting down their supply chain
quite significantly and in fact are
probably expecting the supply chain to
bear a lot of the cost instead of
anything that's going on right now so
let's hope that
this doesn't last for very long and
therefore we convert something you know
slightly more beneficial for smes than
where we are
right this minute but digitalization is
is absolutely essential in terms of
being able to to get the data that that
you need and of course it also allows
you to do a lot in relation to energy
efficiency but in terms of carrots and
sticks that can be offered more
generally of course
the big firms will
be able to incentivize the smaller firms
and suppliers
if they say we're only going to be
buying if you do those very things but
the supplier can also help you make sure
that you do that
so you can be
quite environmentally conscious and do
the right things and therefore you have
a seat at the table if you like in the
sense of being part of a supply chain
but they can also be tax incentives
other type of incentives that mean that
if you do do various things
in a certain way then you can get some
tax credits perhaps particularly for sm
you would matter hugely and then you can
also involve
people who decide on procurement to buy
from firms that do the right thing but
again you have to assume that there is a
capacity for those companies to do that
and as you move further down the the
size then you immediately hit the
problems of can you actually afford it
or do you just go out of business
basically so it's it's a big dilemma and
i think again
uh there needs to be a lot more working
across i think it's interesting when you
look at other countries and the way in
which they manage the supply chain you
know in germany for example the big
firms really support the supply chain
including with loans and so on it's been
happening for a long period of time it
used to happen here as well but that
sort of stopped so there is much more of
a of an industry structure that that
supports that development to take place
we don't quite have that and maybe we
need to go back to to doing so because
otherwise we will lose that ability to
to have a vibrant sme sector which after
all employs
the vast majority of the people in this
country
all right natalie i hope that answered
your question i want to come back to the
theme that we were on i want to come to
you diane talking about that tension
between your bottom line
and the environment you're already
making a technology um
that when we were talking to mark carney
earlier it's exactly in the sweet spot
that needs that turbo boost
of investment
which you'll get when the demand is
there for your product
talk to us about those tensions within
the shipping industry um who've hit the
two been left out of the net zero um
focus haven't they but it is looming
back ahead of cop26 it's expensive to
change the way you power big tankers
isn't it
yeah so you're absolutely right i mean
shipping was excluded from the paris
agreement and um so to your questioner's
point about um you know carrots and
sticks we need both
we need to have shipping included in the
net zero conversation in the zero
emissions conversation at glasgow so
it's absolutely essential that it gets
included in the glasgow accord when it
emerges
but i think what we
um what we're experiencing in real terms
so shipping is responsible for about
three or four percent of global
greenhouse gas emissions that doesn't
sound like a lot everyone says oh that's
not very much but actually all of those
not very much is add up to it's the same
as the uk it's the same as germany's
emissions we're working our socks off in
various developed countries to time to
try and reduce those emissions but
shipping isn't motivated to do that
because it's its commitment is just to
reduce its um greenhouse gas emissions
by 50 by 2050. so that's so far in the
future
and there's no
carrots to do it that it means that we
we all kind of sit there as loads of
really brilliantly kind good people in
the industry want to do something but
the system doesn't enable it for them so
you could be scaling up your technology
if the demand was there if the shipping
industry had the certainty that they
needed to change they also need the
certainty of seeing the technology in
action
and i think it's absolutely rational of
every single ship owner to say i want to
see that working on a real ship before i
buy it i mean i'm not going to buy a
solar panel put it on my roof
if i've not seen it working because it
might bring my house crashing down so i
think it's entirely sensible for those
people to say prove it to me die and
we'll buy it off you we want to buy it
we want to reduce our emissions because
our technology has been demonstrated to
save 20 fuel that's a cost saving you
need to see that they want to see it
they need to kick the tires before they
can do it and that's where the struggle
is to get the finance from innovation
from from invention if you like into
innovation there's a demand pull i've
got loads of letters from ship owners
saying you know build it and we will
come
but we just can't get over that
innovation hump it's a yeah
i hear the frustration with that um a
question coming from our audience from
uh ashley kemker it's a student at
manchester business school i think lindy
this this one is for you and we'll send
our microphone round to you but i think
in a nutshell we'll let you put it put
it to her yourself but it's about
what the government needs to do lindy in
order to get
the labor force suitably skilled up for
a green recovery it's all very well
saying we need to transition but how are
we going to how are we going to retrain
people to do it but actually go ahead
thanks so my question is basically that
the uk economy they have promised that
they would go net zero by 2050 and in
order to achieve that the companies will
have to upscale their products their
processes and along with that their
skills as well and my question is more
related to the skills aspect of it
so in your opinion what is the
government doing and what they should do
additionally
to get the skill force ready and trained
to to embrace say the the future or the
green future
and that's certainly an issue which
concerns a lot of people and within um
within south yorkshire we've had
several economic shocks in that way and
people having to
transition into new employment from
mining from steel
other aspects of heavy industry and
you're right that we need people that
that transition needs to be fair and
people need to be prepared for it both
people who are currently in work but
also
uh young people who will be joining the
workforce over over the next years and
indeed decades and
although it's not a particular area that
friends of the earth is campaigning on
other organizations such as green new
deal certainly have been working a lot
in in that way and a key argument is we
need to get the training right we need
to prepare young people who are moving
into the workforce for the jobs of the
future and not to prepare them for the
jobs that were in the past or indeed the
jobs that
that are already gone but people think
are still going to be available to them
obviously many of the skills can be
applied elsewhere the heavy industry
skills that we developed here are often
now being applied within the advanced
manufacturing
area in on the brotherhood sheffield
border and that that facility and those
skills are being put to good use there
although obviously the another issue is
that we actually need a far smaller
workforce in that way but engineering
skills could be transferred other skills
need to be developed and again it's
about investment somebody mentioned
earlier on the importance of education
and my own background was in education
and i recognize that that is crucially
important both in educating the public
around what the crap how the crisis is
is emerging how it is developing the
seriousness of it but also in how we we
can cope how we can do things
differently how we can be trained up to
work in a different way so yes you're
right that
those things can be done but they'll
only be done with support from outside
because it is not necessarily in the
interests of any current industries to
be training people
up in work that they may or may not want
them to be doing in the future so there
has to be external support for that and
that has to come from the government i
want to come to another question that's
come to us from the audience uh rishabh
are you
out there somewhere
yes there you are um about the
accountability of net zero commitments
who's keeping track to put it to our
panel thank you
we have accountants who are tracking uh
the impact of net zero carbon and we
have companies who are making a plan how
to reduce it but then who's actually
keeping a track of uh
how we are spending the money and even
if we are going in the right direction
and do we have time and resources that
if there's a possible downside
to the entire scenario uh do we have
time and money to
come back uh and build this
so i suppose the question is touching on
really to what extent are pledges
genuine to what extent are they green
washing who's even keeping track brief
word from the olynyk i have no idea
who's keeping track but i am
fairly confident that there's an awful
lot of green washing going on i was
fascinated by the
the graphic that was put up earlier
about the the way in which companies
have been making promises and have been
committing to things and can be shown to
be doing
taking action and reducing emissions and
that is much less true of um of working
at government level
and that is definitely something that
needs to be taken account of more it's
very easy to talk it's very easy to make
promises and pledges and say we're going
to do these wonderful things we know
that it is harder to do the next step
and nobody's going to say that that's
easy but definitely the steps need to be
taken and it's not enough to come up
with a great big you know plan and a
promise without actually having a
delivery uh a delivery plan behind that
um and the commitments that have been
made in the exhortations that have been
made are insufficient and this is i'm
sure we're going to get onto cop26 but
you know that is the the big issue
around cop26 that so many promises are
going to be made and it's going to be
glitzy and and glamorous and you know on
the tv all the time and people are going
to get credit for great big
announcements but actually there's a lot
of work that needs to be done behind
that and sometimes the glitz and the
glamour and the announcements can
actually uh distract from the fact that
very little is going on we'll come on
we'll finish actually by talking about
our hopes and fears for cop 26. but
actually just want to come back to you
on that very question i mean your pledge
to cut emissions by 30 by 2030 who keeps
track of that
so we we follow a science-based uh
target system where it's audited uh by
accountants as you talk about as well
and i think the key thing for us is some
of our pledges are not as far-reaching
as other people in the industry but we
have had years of taking action and
delivering on our promises and what
that's taught us
is actually it's very important to make
far-reaching commitments so we think
that's important because it it talks
about the aspiration the leadership
behind it but it's how you follow up on
it so i think measurement is really
important commitment at operational
level
as well as at leadership level and then
being very clear on the programs that
drive improvement whether it's on farm
in factory or actually in the way that
we move products
so actually for for us we spend much
more energy and how do we bring things
to life in reality
than the pledges uh that we make
and the way that we do that is in the
way that we follow up on data
so our data collection not only on on
farm for instance is is annual and and
every year we publish
uh in a transparent way the summary of
all of those results but what we also do
is we individually share that with our
farmers
so in an anonymized way that they can
then see how they compare to the average
farmer and so on and see where they can
improve so for me it's very much about
being able to measure have programs just
one thing that diane said that i thought
was a really really important point to
pick up on and the role of government as
well
it's quite often in the early days there
is that balance in terms of cost versus
investment and does it pay off but that
can often uh be improved by being able
to scale the idea so i think for me
scaling is also really important and
therefore government can really
play a hand there in terms of
inter-industry collaboration to be able
to really scale some of these ideas so
they aren't an economic kind of negative
uh for people to make the the
investments
really interesting uh final word really
from each of you about um
i mean you sound a little skeptical
lindy if you don't mind me saying about
what we might get out of cop 26. so how
are you feeling about it vicky and what
are you going to be looking for
specifically
there's so much that's been said before
the actual meeting so the expectations
have have varied there's some who are
quite optimistic about it bringing loads
of commitments together and others who
think that it would be a little bit like
before when
uh all sorts of pleasures were made and
they weren't uh followed and i think the
example of the latter
is um to do with transferring money to
developing countries which absolutely
need to adapt and also
um have some technology transfer which
is absolutely essential and it was that
money that 100 billion a year was
pledged in 2009 was that exactly and
here we are and very little is being
dispatched every year and now they said
they'd do it because everyone's been
also doubling or increasing the amount
that they had pledged originally but of
course very little of that money had
ever gone
um so that's the real worry about coming
up with loads of commitments which sound
good but perhaps don't
take account of the reality in the short
term and they don't take account of the
transition period that is required to
get to where you want to be and all
those
sticks and carrots that are absolutely
essential
at the end of the day i'm afraid it
comes to regulation whether it's
shipping or anywhere else and money and
if that money isn't available
taking risks with technology
really into spreading that risk as well
making sure all the stuff we've just
been hearing about in terms of being
able to scale up uh for example carbon
capture and storage uh it's still being
tried there are a number of
possibilities that will be decided
pretty quickly in the uk as well it's
been going on for decades that type of
discussion
and and we're still not really there so
it just takes too long to make those
decisions and too little money is
actually being spent and if you just
look at what is required between now and
2030 of course cop 26 is going to be
looking at the ultimate you know
temperature increase and really you know
looking at all the evidence science that
we've just been talking about um which
is saying that we we're nearly there
already in terms of the 1.5
centigrade increase and we've already
are at 1.1 nothing 1.2 so there really
isn't very much time so it's crucial
what happens between now and 2030 and
that amount of money is now being
recalculated in terms of what is needed
so
just the the european union is saying
that what they need to be spending is
360 billion a year between now and 2030
and 125 billion
of uh digitalization which is absolutely
essential now you know i mentioned
earlier that they're putting out the
first bond for 20 billion well that's
very very little by comparison to what
is actually needed and i think it's the
ambition that has to be there and has to
be if you like measured and monitored um
in terms of how they do from here on it
starts the ball rolling
but it shouldn't start the ball rolling
it's it should just push it further i
mean the bulls should really have
started
a long time ago yeah yeah and uh word
from you lindy about what you're hoping
to see
it's a great opportunity here in the uk
that um that glasgow is the host for cop
26 and um and i know that there's plenty
of opportunity for the uk to be making
its own promises and announcements a
huge concern though and it links with
with um
uh with something that both vicky and um
and diane said is that at the same time
we are in the uk have not
um
we are still looking at developing a
massive oil field west of shetland the
cambo oil field and this will be
equivalent in its emissions to 18 coal
fired power stations it's also going to
be vastly expensive so um blackrock who
you mentioned is having you know
billions of
dollars available for investment are one
of the key players in thinking that they
will invest within cambo
um so you have a bit of a perfect storm
there of lots of money that could be
spent in other ways being spent on
uh exploiting fossil fuels now the
government have the opportunity to say
no this camp this can't happen we are
not going to allow the exploitation in
that way because at the moment there's a
huge degree of hypocrisy in insisting on
other countries doing their bit when
we're not taking those sort of stands
ourselves there is money available both
in the private sector and indeed the
public sector because as diane pointed
out we are um just about the the the
country with the most favorable regime
in terms of uh
tax credits and an actual um
funding support uh and subsidies for
fossil fuels
and lots of oil and gas companies want
to be based here but we need to address
that because the money is there to do
the sort of things which are needed to
be done
and they need to be done very quickly so
we're hoping that the uk will take a
stand that
diana had wanted to come to you for a
final word from you about what you hope
to get out of cop 26 but i'm being told
that we are all out of time i'm afraid
unless you could do it in one sentence
so yes repurposing oil and gas workers
through a series of events that we're
doing at malin which is just opposite
cop26 where we're bringing the whole
shipping industry together
to create an action plan through
the
oil and gas sector transferring their
knowledge and expertise into green power
for shipping that's what we want to do
at clock26 and that's what we're doing
okay all right we are out of time i hope
you enjoyed that panel discussion got
through as much as we could there
there's so much obviously that we could
still talk about i'm going to give you
all a 15-minute comfort break now and
when you come back trevor phillips is
going to be hosting a panel all about
the levelling up agenda so we hope to
see you back for that
[Applause]
[Music]
you